de toutes les municipalités dont vous
avez entendu parler ce soir c'est celle
de mascouche soulève le plus de
questions
nous interrogeons sur des relations
troublante entre le maire et certains
entrepreneurs favoritisme copinage une
municipalité où les opposants ont
littéralement peur de parler ou le
député provincial créer des représailles
et où le maire et la pluie et le beau
temps
mascouche dans lanaudière 39000 362
habitants
le taux de participation lors des
dernières élections 47%
deux candidats se font la lutte pour le
poste de maire
richard marcotte a été réélu
trois conseillers sur 8 représente
l'opposition
ouch s'élève à 62 millions de dollars
richard marcotte est un gagnant il règne
depuis près de 20 ans sur une banlieue
prospère trois dernières années plus de
450 nouveaux avis en quelques années
mascouche est devenu un véritable pôle
d'attraction la population il a presque
doublé les condos et maisons y poussent
comme des champignons
même la sûreté du québec a choisi
mascouche pour son tout nouveau quartier
général sur la rive nord
c'est votre royaume
trois points de royaume c'est une
réalisation
richard marcotte et le candidat de jean
charest aux élections de 2003 il n'est
pas élu mais les libéraux le nomme
l'année suivante au conseil
d'administration de l'école nationale de
police richard marcotte joue bien ses
cartes
grâce à lui mascouche obtient le train
de l'est wask chercher j'ai toujours
fait ça dans ma vie où est l'argent
jean-guy ouellette doit sa fortune au
développement spectaculaire de mascouche
où il a construit 1500 maisons
c'est lui qui fonde en 1990 le parti du
ralliement mascouche et ils se cherchent
un gagnant un choix s'impose au sto
s'est développé à porter le commissaire
industriel de la région
richard marcotte j'ai pensé que
peut-être ça c'est un bon candidat pour
nous parce qu'il était une personne un
peu connu marc est élu où elle est il
satisfait en public
le nouveau maire est acclamé
augmentation cette année des taxes 0
saint paul a demandé ce matin nous en
priver c'est une autre histoire
plusieurs reprises il ne parlait que
dans d'autres villes le maire avait des
avantages come back pourrait pas vivre
seulement qu'avec le salaire qu'il
recevait il voulait que je lui fournisse
une maison gratuitement
c'est quand mes valeurs puis c'est quand
les plus jamais dans le passé pour des
maisons la personne à part mon épouse
c'est une autre demande marcotte qui va
sceller le divorce politique entre les
deux hommes
il m'avait déjà laissé sous-entendre que
pour travailler à mascouche on devrait
participer
au financement du parti politique un
moment donné il m'est arrivé il m'a dit
tiens jean-guy socialistes de toutes les
formes bizarres mais moi je n'avais
vraiment pas le teint et le goût de
rencontrer tous ces gens là puis
commencer à faire des pressions
si on voulait travailler à mascouche on
devait
la remettre une partie des contrats un
casse n'a pas beaucoup d'autres façons
c'était il ya 15 ans récemment le maire
en redemande est un cadeau de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de dollars
mascouche a beau être à l'aise de
montréal c'est un peu le far west on
finance un projet immobilier et dans le
cas de ce financement le promoteur nous
a communiqué que le maire de mascouche
l'avait approché pour obtenir un condo
arabe et jeu qu'on a refusé nous de
consentir comme rabais sur le prix de
vente mais je pense que ça ça montre un
peu commun le système et organisent à
mascouche
c'est au plus fort la poche la requête
est refusée par le banquier mais
certains développeurs ont été
apparemment plus indulgent c'est le cas
de luigi salvatore un gros moteur
prospère au nombre de ses réalisations
de projets à mascouche
cette résidence de personnes âgées et ce
complexe immobilier du centre-ville en
2004 luigi salvatore et vente à richard
marcotte deux condos dans cet édifice
cent mille dollars chacun soit 30% en
bas du prix du marché
deux ans plus tard richard marcotte les
revend à la fiducie familiale de luigi
salvatore profit de monsieur le maire 45
mille dollars pour un condo et 35000
dollars pour l'autre
luigi salvatore a refusé nous parlait il
ya quelques temps le maire fait faire
des aménagements chez lui il demande à
l'ouvrier d'envoyer la facture aux plus
gros entrepreneurs de la ville saturée
transport et excavation mascouche le
pays par transport et excavation
mascouche transport et excavation
mascouche appartient normand trudel
cet entrepreneur récolte sa large part
des contrats de la ville
de 2000 à 2009 il y en a pour près de 40
millions de dollars terrain de foot ball
park a que du dépôt de neige usée
les compagnies de normand trudel fond de
tout même du déneigement
l'appel d'offres pour ce contrat soulève
des questions
ce que je remarque c'est ce que tous des
critères qui tendent un restreindre la
concurrence
moi si je peux citoyens la ville de je
ne cautionnerai là les exigences à
savoir pourquoi ce que demande étant dec
d'exigence à son esprit somme à une
faune d'autres entreprises qui étaient
tout à fait compétente
le tournoi de golf annuel de
nation richard marcotte est un événement
incontournable
jusqu'à tout récemment normand trudel et
el presidente cette fondation
cette bonne oeuvre hamas les dons pour
promouvoir le sport chez les jeunes
et ça marche récemment
cette fondation n'apparaît pas sur la
liste des organismes de bienfaisance de
l' agence du revenu du canada
elle ne peut donc donné de reçu d'impôt
et ses activités économiques et châteaux
regard du public
la fondation du sahara marcotte avait
jusqu'à l'an dernier la même adresse que
transport et excavation mascouche
normand trudel ne fait pas de cachette
de sa relation privilégiée avec le maire
il s'en vante même où nouveau député de
masson j'étais au bureau de chute trudel
parce que m'avait téléphoné il m'a dit
tu sais les agapes dr richard marcotte
puis elle dit si je me suis leur fait un
trou de cul benzerga douce qui a rendu
aujourd'hui mais ça se passe qui
travaillent avec moi ils un jour tu veux
te rendre leurs avoirs voir qu'on
travaillé ensemble la familiarité qui
existe entre normand trudel et le maire
a même attiré l'attention du bureau du
directeur général des élections
dans un rapport effectué en 2000 dans le
vaste dossier des élections clés en main
un enquêteur rapporte ce témoignage
excavation mascouche fait le magouillage
politique ou profil du parti ralliement
mascouche
tous les fournisseurs de services à
mascouche lorsqu'il obtient le contrat
donne 5 % du montant du contrat
à la caisse occulte le dge n'a pas donné
suite à ce rapport
l'organisme a refusé de répondre à nos
questions mais une chose est certaine
par ailleurs à mascouche
la rumeur d'une caisse occulte et
persistante jean-guy ouellette aimerait
bien que ses collègues entrepreneurs en
parle ouvertement si on pas une
enveloppe a donné sa repos mais les
autres ils vont payer pour passer en
avant toi fait que tu payes pote bien
beau d'avoir qu'est ce que tu as besoin
mais ça prend du temps
l'automne dernier une controverse éclate
à mascouche et attire l'attention des
médias sur une des compagnies de normand
trudel
écolosol un site d'entreposage de sols
contaminés
le site écolosol ne jamais eu
l'autorisation autant de la ville de
mascouche que du ministère de
l'environnement pour faire du graphisme
normand trudel anna ceci dans cette
entreprise
antonio accurso accurso possède un
bateau sur lequel richard marcotte a
séjourné après son mariage en 2007 en
compagnie de sa femme et de normand
trudel était allé en voyage sur le
bateau de richard marcotte est allé au
moins une autre fois sur le bateau
d'antonio accurso
cet entrepreneur brasse ou si d'autres
affaires dans la région
sa compagnie construction lui
ou a obtenu par appel d'offres en 2008
un contrat de 12 millions de dollars de
la régie d'assainissement des eaux usées
de terrebonne mascouche régie dont le
président était richard marcotte
je dépose les pétitions demandant votre
démission ainsi que les seize conseils
jusqu'au don à prouver
dans son compte de taxes plus
l'entourage du maire n'apprécie pas
d'être remises en question ce citoyen
s'est fait rabrouer après une assemblée
pour avoir critiqué l'administration
marcotte
ce soir là il y avait un membre du
cabinet du maire qui m'a apostrophé et
qui m'a carrément dit que si je
continuais comme ça que j'allais avoir
des problèmes à mascouche peu de gens
acceptent de se confier
certains sont même convaincus d'être sur
écoutes
il est vrai que dans les années 90 le
maire a contribué à enregistrer la ligne
privés d'une de ses employées qui l'a
ensuite congédier un fait révélée dans
le procès opposant huguette houle et la
ville de mascouche le député de masson
lui s'est fait rabrouer par normand
trudel
après avoir dénoncé les activités
d'écolosol oui je pense que c'est pas
qui tu parles
ces deux mondes pas de menacer le terme
est peut-être un peu ton ferme et
d'intimider le j'ai raccroché et
secondes plus tard mon téléphone grâce à
des puits mennecy l'aï dit je pense que
tu sais vraiment pas qui tu parles
normand trudel pitt for mayor j'éprouve
souviennent de moi pour que je vous dis
oui oui j'ai jugé us je parle
normand trudel n'a jamais répondu à nos
appels
pareil comme les élèves à la petite
école il ya des gens qui ont le pouvoir
ou qui sont plus forts et profite de
cette situation là pour taxer
je n'aurais des entrevues tard
ça me garde est posté via
nous continuerons à nous intéresser de
près à mascouche dans les prochaines
semaines avec de nouvelles révélations
troublantes
un projet de loi sur l'éthique et la
déontologie dans les municipalités est
actuellement en préparation où ils
servent affaires municipales
ce projet de loi 109 devrait être
adoptée prochainement
reste à savoir qu'il appliquera et
comment